this is the upper end of the vowel race'
a valley that rises into the Levantine
alps from the lago maggiore it's home to
the AL grot cafe Angelo and Cynthia
capella restored an old grotto here to
serve as a restaurant in the Italian
speaking part of switzerland grotty are
known as rustic restaurants they serve
local delicacies outside used to be in
the past place where people would sell
their own stuff they produce like salami
cheese wine and then during the period
has become like a restaurant but
normally in a grotto we should serve
local stuff we try to keep alive this
part of our culture for euromax Angelo
capela prepares a traditional ticino
dish polenta with Peoria cheese gratin a
the polenta or cornmeal mush is cooked
according to local traditions it's
seasoned only with salt and is made with
three different grinds of cornmeal
cinzia capela fetches the peora cheese
from a seller hewn into the rock
in my opinion is one of the best years
we have here in the southern part of
Switzerland and it's not very available
it is limited quantities so we are lucky
to have about 30 say three forms per
year the AL poppy or cheese dairy is
located at an altitude of some 2,000
meters it produces around 20 tons of
cheese per year pra casa good 40 euros a
kilo that makes it the most expensive
cheese in Switzerland the manager
audrianna doll fini is proud of his
dairies product PR Akkad is naturally
capogiro cheese depends on the flora
methane this valley is special we're
fortunate that it runs from east to west
so both slopes get sunlight the whole
day Austin knock westin feet we have
quite a lot of flowers in this valley
over a thousand varieties there fila
bloom and order be there out and we get
lots of little storms so that's good for
the grass and the pastures grind
aggravate it on that is good and a good
pasture gives good milk which is a
prerequisite for good cheese Mila poder
de dieta para llevar por guten Kathy the
PRA is aged for several months in the
crisp mountain air and brushed with salt
water every other day the ripened cheese
then goes to the AL grot cafe
this peora is very tasty especially
after one year of aging it becomes very
very tough in taste time is also an
important factor in the polenta the
cornmeal mush has to simmer for at least
three hours to get its special taste
maybe every five minutes you turn it
like that just to avoid that addressed
on the bottom there is a culture that's
the culture finally the marsh is done
the polenta is covered with the slice of
pyara and placed into the oven for 10
minutes the oven is fired with beech
wood from the nearby forest and the
Ticino specialty is ready to eat if you
look around here is all nature so take
it easy just relax and give us the
necessary time to serve you and you will
see you will enjoy our food is all the
prepare with love and this you will feel
it in our dishes a visit to the out rock
cafe is like a journey back to the roots
of ticino cuisine its regional simple
and hearty